foreign
I'm really glad to get to share
something with you that I've been
working on for the past 15 years
but more importantly something that
could become the first specimen of an
entire new industry that we might find
all around the planet over the next
decades
think of it as something like the very
first smartphone still quite clumsy and
quite expensive but of transformative
technology
smartphones have changed the way how we
communicate
this I hope could change the way how we
deal with global warming this is orca
this is the first worldwide commercial
direct air capture and storage plant it
is in Iceland and it is an industrial
plant that extracts CO2 out of ambient
air we've operated now for more than one
year it costs more than 10 million
dollars to build orca
and its modules
those eight boxes that we call CO2
collectors they are designed to extract
a bit more than 10 tons of carbon
dioxide from the air every day
that sounds quite expensive
however when thinking about cost we
should keep in mind one thing there is
one thing that we cannot buy and that is
time
and we need to be quite fast here
so that is why
Orca is not there to demonstrate costs
Orca is there
to show in the field out there in the
weather
that the plant is operating and orca is
working
so the next step for us at climb works
and for all the other companies in the
field is now going forward improving the
technology
scaling it up from tens to hundreds to
millions of tons capacity and as we as
we as we go ahead
and we scale that up with every new
plant going online
we'll have efficiencies going up and
we'll have costs going down
now how does it work in the case of orca
we have fans mounted to the CO2
collectors that draw air through them
inside there is a filter material that
we call sorbent a highly porous material
and as the air pulls through it the CO2
is bound at the surface of this material
think of it as a sponge that is sucks up
water in its pores we do that for a
certain time until the material is
filled with used CO2 it is saturated and
we close the modules we heat them up to
around 100 degrees Celsius and we can
extract concentrated CO2 from them
the good thing is that the main energy
input that we need for that process is
low temperature Heat at around 100
degrees Celsius
and it can entirely be powered by
renewable energy
now that looks quite easy at first
glance right and indeed the process
behind that is quite simple
however when it comes to implementing
that into reality in the field out there
with the purpose of having a plant that
is constantly operating 24 7 reliably
then it becomes quite challenging let me
give you two examples why it is a
challenge to capture and remove CO2 from
the air
first of all there is not a lot of CO2
in the air we're currently at around 420
PPM
that means
one molecule out of 2500 molecules in
the air around us is CO2 that's not a
lot and that means to extract only one
ton of CO2 from the air we need to
filter around 2 million cubic meters of
air that's about 800 Olympic swimming
pools
and there's another way of picturing
that what I which I personally find
quite puzzling imagine one of these
filters with an inlet area of one meter
by one meter
and the amount of air like think of it
as a block of air that you have to push
through that filter Inlet to take just
one ton of CO2 out of the air
is 2 000 kilometers long
another example why this is a challenge
is that it is not so easy to find good
actually the best solvent materials
which are both High performing
and which can Prevail outside there in
the field with a long life
now on this next picture you see
Kristoff and myself co-founders of climb
works in the very early days of Klein
Works working on that
the very first sorbents we produce them
with our own hands such as you would do
your laundry if you didn't have a
washing machine we set some sorbents on
fire
and we produced hundreds of samples in
the past 10 years
looking forward
thousands of more will come very likely
now this is one way of doing it we are
doing that in our company but many
others are doing it there are companies
out there startups more established
companies and researchers and scientists
and that is a good thing because the
challenge ahead of us that is immense
now let's step back and look at it at
the big picture so where does this kind
of Technology fit into our overall fight
against climate change and it's
important that first and foremost the
most important thing we need to do is
and we'll always say the DraStic
reduction of a mission of missions of
greenhouse gases without that we will
have no chance of ever meeting any of
our climate goals
then in a second step it will be
important that we can all ramp up
the capacity of extracting and removing
CO2 from the atmosphere
now when thinking about the letters so
far I've spoken about technology but we
shouldn't forget that also nature offers
several solutions to extract carbon from
the air such as forests and oceans and
one element that is very important will
be doubling down on these methods
offered by Nature enhancing them and
protecting them
that is important however will it be
sufficient to rely only on nature-based
carbon sinks very likely not
trees need time to grow and forests need
space and there is simply just not
enough area available to plant entire
continents of new forests which we would
need in order to capture many billions
of tons of CO2 from the atmosphere
and therefore besides preserving all
these nature-based Solutions and
enhancing them it will be very important
to scale up technology-based solutions
for large-scale carbon removal from the
atmosphere
now I often get asked if you build
direct air capture plants like the one
we saw before is that a license to
continue polluting
it is clearly not direct air capture is
not a silver bullet but it is a
must-have
had we stopped emitting 20 30 years ago
or at least substantially reduced our
emissions climb works and this whole
emerging industry around us would likely
not be here today
and for the climate that would probably
be the better solution
however that's not where we are today
the ipcc has indicated in their last
report that technological
technology-based solutions to remove
carbon from the air are in acidity and
they included it into their models
and that is why this anti-industry that
is currently emerging now needs to
Double Down On Moving from small scale
and relatively expensive to larger scale
and cheap
double down on developing deploying
learning and adjusting in the field
we have to develop markets we have to
develop policy
and we have to develop
mechanisms to to analyze the CO2 capture
and other technical ways of removing CO2
that take care of the fact that by
taking CO2 out of the air with machines
and putting it down the ground we have
one of the most permanent ways of
storing the CO2 away for millions of
years
now let's get back one step and let's
get back to today where we are let's get
back to the presence to what is concrete
let's get back to Iceland and our Orca
plant I've told you before how these
collectors extract CO2 from the air now
how do we make sure that it really
permanently stays locked away
for that reason in Iceland we'd have
partnered up with the company carp fix
that have developed a method for
permanent carbon storage through
mineralization
what they do is they take the CO2 mix it
with water and inject it into
underground volcanic so-called basiled
rock formations that is one of the most
abundant stone or stone material that
you find on Earth
and by doing so the CO2 binds with the
rock it mineralizes and it literally
turns into stone within two years
hundreds of meters Underground
the good thing about that method is that
it is very tangible and it's very easy
to understand for that purpose I've
brought this rock sample here for you
that is taken actually from a from a
drill core of a bizal drug formation
hundreds of meters underground and what
you can see here that's a black rock
which is the black basalt rock
containing some white crystals and these
crystals are CO2 turned into stone and
the ground and locked away
[Applause]
now I explained you one method of doing
this there are several other methods out
there
are several other techniques other
Technologies but the important thing
about is that this thing is is out there
it's in practice it's operating and we
are learning from it and that is so
essential for this new industry and we
have learned a lot actually
we have learned how to operate on hot
dry summer days
learn to operate them in pouring rain
and we even had to learn how to operate
them on a just normal day
we had to learn how to ramp up the Orca
plant immediately after an Icelandic
snowstorm
and this all is what we need in order to
deploy these plans all over the world we
should deploy them all over the world
because we do need so many of them we
can't deploy them all over the world
because the air is everywhere around us
and the CO2
is almost the same concentration
everywhere where we are so it doesn't
matter where we capture the CO2 and for
that reason and the spirit of deploying
more in June of this year we have
announced the next step on our climb
work scale up roadmap which is named
Mammoth and that is what you see here
that is a plan which is nine times
larger than the Orca plant that will be
in Iceland as well
and the first tons of CO2 will be
captured by the end of 2023
this winter we will finalize the first
building before the snow starts
now that is a big challenge ahead of us
and actually you can only really
understand what this challenge is and
really quantify it if you build these
things out there make mistakes and learn
from them
so it's a hard problem it's not a simple
problem to solve and there is no easy
solution to it but without action like
this there is no solution at all
and so when I started looking back at
the last 15 years what we have been
doing I'm now looking forward to the
next 15 years that are to come because
that is what we need thank you
[Applause]
foreign